Rolling Stone is also Under Fire after
the mag took aim at the weekend's
upcoming HBO series their sources
calling it quote sexual torture porn and
disgustingly off the rails
fire up the mic let's go the Idol stars
Lily Rose Depp Dan Levy and the weekend
as a modernized cult leader his response
to the article Rolling Stone did we
upset you rolling stone
are they a little irrelevant submerged
sir the crossfire is all about the
Magazine's recent expose which featured
interviews with 13 unnamed cast and crew
members who called out the weekend and
the show's co-creator Sam Levinson they
labeled the Euphoria Creator a toxic man
who wanted to turn the estimated 75
million dollar project into Euphoria
season 3 with pop stars adding
disturbing sexual and physically violent
scenes I need full control
the sources allege when Levinson took
over in 2021 he completely rewrote and
re-shot it to switch Focus from Lily
Rose's character to the weekends it was
like the weekend wanted one show that
was all about him Sam was on board with
that the dark place that was painful I
think for everyone involved in making it
I know it was hard for me Sam is no
stranger to criticism euphoria's Sydney
Sweeney and Minka Kelly both pushed back
on his demands for nude scenes but Lily
Rose is coming to the director's defense
telling E.T today he created an
environment in which I felt seen heard
and appreciated no official comment from
Sam or the weekend Los Angeles is where
all the monsters of the world come
together trust no one
let's move on now to Priscilla Presley
as she battles to take control of Lisa
Marie's trust she's starting a new
Venture and yes Elvis is involved it's
crazy don't you think
Priscilla voices herself in Netflix's
new animated series agent Elvis out
March 17th meanwhile granddaughter Riley
hit the Late Show to promote her new
Prime video series Daisy Jones and the
six which premieres tomorrow your Elvis
Presley's granddaughter one of the
questions they asked me when I signed on
was will you play would you go on tour
and I was like yeah sure whatever you
know you kind of just like
lie to get jobs so
foreign